this is from sports illustrated it says
nascar announced tuesday that denny
hamlin will be required to complete a
sensitivity training course that must
begin by the end of the week according
to a league spokesperson the cup series
driver made a social media post on
monday using an anti-asian meme from the
television show family guy toward kyle
larson regarding his final lap move
in uh sunday's tallydega super speedway
and this is he's being accused of racism
it was where we're being told and this
was sports illustrated said in their
headlines a racist joke that um hamlin
made a racist joke about this other
nascar driver hamlin tweeted i took down
a post i made earlier today after
reading some of the comments it was a
poor choice of memes and i saw how it
was offensive it came across totally
wrong i apologize
larson who is half japanese and the
reigning cup series champion made a move
in his final turn that helped him finish
fourth overall in the race however this
move was an aggressive one that uh
caused a crash
and okay so you have larson
half japanese does something during the
race causes a crash and then denny
hamlin
uh another nascar driver tweets out this
meme kind of like making a joke about it
from family guy and in fact we have the
meme before it was deleted and uh he was
sent off to sensitivity training camp
before that here's here's what he posted
let's watch it here
how much signal i need to cut across
eight lane none i turn now good luck
everybody else
[Music]
i think it's funny um
you know there was a there was a a time
when you could i mean that's family guy
that's not a that's not a show from
from 70 years ago so like not all that
long ago you could make jokes like that
so here's a couple of things
we're being so this is a this is a
racist joke and of course pamela's
apologized for it and he's calling the
sensitivity training and all the rest of
it
um
but
maybe we should ask like is that
actually a racist joke and
the answer is no
it in fact does not
okay
and i know this may be very shocking for
lots of people to hear
but a joke a a racial
joke
is not automatically racist it's not
okay because racism racist these are
this this is a word that means something
and what it means is that if you're a
racist person if you're making a racist
statement
then it's a statement that another
race
um or
or ethnicity is
inferior to you
like you you don't like them they're
inferior
and um and you're better than them
that's that's that's that's what racism
is
there's nothing in that little meme
there
that even implies anything like that
it doesn't imply that he hates asian
people it doesn't imply that he thinks
asian people are inferior to him
but yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a
stereotype
so you're just having a little bit of
fun with the stereotype
and it's slightly edgy and yeah it might
be a little bit it could be offensive
that's the other thing that might be
shocking for people to hear a joke can
be racial
and even offensive i mean i don't think
it's offensive but it could be a could
be racial and offensive but not racist
if you can believe it
so if you want to call that offensive
that's a little bit offensive
maybe
it's not racist
and and here's the other thing
it is a sign of progress
when you can make jokes like that
okay when you can make racial jokes
and ethnic jokes
that's a sign of progress in society
so kind of like where we were
in say the 90s
which i which which right now is is the
has to i guess be the the pinnacle of uh
of
interracial relations in america
because
you can make jokes like that
and no one really got offended and
everyone you had different people making
jokes about other people and uh and
that's it it was just a joke you'd laugh
about it that's a sign of progress
it's just like if someone if you're if
you're friends with someone you can make
jokes about them
that people who are not their friends
can't make
so it's actually a sign of affection and
familiarity when you can kind of joke
around with your friends it's especially
the case with guys
uh maybe a little bit less so with women
but that's a general principle when you
could joke around with someone make
jokes that uh maybe in another context
from somebody else would be offensive
but this is a sign of you're familiar
your friends it's actually a show of
affection
and so when you're in a society where
people of different ethnicities and
races can make jokes about each other
and it's all in good fun and you just
kind of laugh about it that's progress
and so the fact that we have now reached
a point
where we cannot make any jokes at all
on racial grounds
um that means that we've regressed
because we used to be able to do that
and now we can't that's regression
but that's not a sign that uh that race
relations have improved it's a sign of
the opposite happening
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated